à l'image du banquet de mathilda may
c'est une saison joyeuse et déchaîné qui
attend montigny le bretonneux avec 38
spectacles programmés la ville a choisi
de miser sur la surprise il ya cette
recherche en tout cas aussi de pouvoir
attirer un public plus jeune
on a aussi beaucoup misé sur du
burlesque cette année je pense notamment
au banquet
que mathilda may présenter elle-même
comme une oeuvre théâtrale non
identifiés des valeurs sûres et des
prises de risque du rire avec pablo
mirail patrick bosso de la musique avec
grand corps malade et de la magie le roi
du transformisme arturo brachetti
s'arrête à la ferme du manuel en février
la priorité c'est avant tout de faire
plaisir aux gens
avec expérience avec les années on sait
aujourd'hui ce que les gens comme
desiderata mais néanmoins ceci nous
empêche pas chaque année d'essayer de
mettre en place des spectacles
différents parfois surprenants c'est le
cas cette année et des moments d'émotion
aussi le 11 mars richard berry fait ses
plaidoiries et celle de grandes affaires
judiciaires du procès de bobigny à celui
de véronique courjault
on cherche le tap de la vérité c'est un
moment exceptionnel il ya une prestation
de deux comédiens qui est absolument
extraordinaire
une mise en scène qu'il est tout aussi
des spectacles familiaux vont aussi
rythmé la saison la salle jacques brel
et la ferme du manet vous attendent dès
le 29 septembre pour une saison
éclectique